in this lesson we're going to talk about
the unit circle and some examples
related to the unit circle now the unit
circle is a big concept uh we're just
going to go through some sample problems
here to get you you know refresh your
memory and get get started with this but
i'll have a link to
my mario's math tutoring youtube channel
where i go deeper into the unit circle
and how to work with that if you need to
review that further i'll have that link
for you but let's do these couple
examples here see if you can do them on
your own
and we'll do them go over them together
in the standard xy coordinate plane okay
below an angle is shown where the vertex
is the origin one side of this angle
with measure theta passes through
negative 512 and the other side includes
the positive x-axis what is the sine of
theta okay so the drawing that we're
looking at here is this you're going
negative 5 12 that's right about there
okay
your angle here is theta and here's the
positive x-axis so what we're looking
for is we're looking for the sine of
this angle
now we know our sohcahtoa our acronym
right the sine
is the opposite side over the hypotenuse
what we need to do here is we need to
drop a perpendicular this coordinate
right here is negative 5 12 which means
that we're going left 5
up 12 and if we do the pythagorean
theorem a squared plus b squared equals
c squared this hypotenuse is 13 okay and
so now that we've got all three sides if
you want to find the sign of this angle
can you position yourself here at the
center okay
at the origin the sine is the opposite
side over the hypotenuse so that's going
to be 12 13. so it looks like the best
answer here is letter b so again it's
you know drawing the triangle dropping
the perpendicular finding the missing
side and knowing your sohcahtoa acronym
in order to find the ratio of the sides
example number two it says what are the
values between 0 degrees and 360 degrees
where the sine of theta is negative one
half again you want to just refresh on
the unit circle here sine is the y value
on the unit circle we're wondering where
does sine equal negative one-half well
it's going to be negative one-half at
these two angles right here these are 30
degree reference angles and so this if
you measure from here this is actually
going to be 180 plus 30 which is 210
and then this is going to be 360 minus
30 which is 330
so it looks like the best answer here is
letter d now
on the act of course you could work
backwards you know you've got your
multiple choice answers you could just
go on your calculator sine of 210 does
that give me negative one-half sine of
330 does that give me negative one-half
okay i know i got it so you can always
use that back substitution technique
sometimes on certain problems it could
be more time consuming but on this
problem it's pretty straight forward you
just go ahead and put in your angle take
the sign of it and double check you just
want to make sure that your mode on your
calculator is set to degrees since these
are in degrees
and you got it so i'll see you in the
next lesson